رجل الاعمال المثير للجدل يودع السجن على
خلفيه ياتهم تتعلق بالتامر على امن الدوله
الداخليه والخارجيه التتبع القضائي لا
يتوقف عند لطيف بل يشمل سياسيين محسوبين
على حركه النهضه ورجال اعمال واعلاميين
وكذلك كوادر امنيه اما نور الدين البحيري
الرجل الثاني في حركه النهضه وزير العدل
الاسبق فيطبع الان في السجن واتهم مواجهه
اليها تسليم جوازات سفر الى ارهابيين
وتدليس احكام قضائيه ووثائق رسميه وفي
الجانب الاعلامي من القضيه تم الاحتفاظ
بالصحفي نور الدين بوتار مدير عام اذاعه
موزاييك فاما الخاصه على خلفيه جوانب
تتعلق بتسيير المؤسسه ماليا واداريا مع
توجيه اسئله له حول خطها التحريري خصومه
هذه الشخصيات مع قيس سعيد
يختلف بدرجه الحده ودرجه الخطوره ايضا لكن
الخيط الناظمه بينها باستثناء القاضيين
اما البقيه فاعتقد ان ما يجمعها هو ما رشح
من اسباب روجت له الدوائر الرسميه حول
مساله المؤامره التي قيل انها حركت في
منزل خيام التركي
والشخصيه المحوريه لهذه المجموعه هو كمال
الطيف ويبدو انه هو النواه او الدائره
المركزيه لهذه المجموعه انصحت فعلا نظريه
المؤامره والتي لم يستطع الخطاب الرسمي
الى حد الان ان يبررها او ان يقنع بها